Ricky is in San Angelo Texas
hi Ricky welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I've been listening to
your podcast really on radio for the
last three months or so and I'm trying
to get my wife on board
you know we've have to do in our taxes
and looking at what we make and what we
don't have in the bank I kinda want to
change how we're doing things in the
future so I didn't want to be advice or
a little bit of help on how to get her
on board
she's just hesitant or pretty anything
about it mm-hmm
what she hasn't something about well
really she thinks he can't do the
program she thinks it's just something
that you know is unrealistic and started
living that way and cutting back and
budgeting and that type of thing it she
just thinks it's uh unrealistic really
that's one of the things mmm
so what's your household income we make
about a hundred and sixty thousand okay
bye and so it's unrealistic to live on
less than 160,000 right that's what I'm
thinking but you know I've explained it
and gone over hey you know I listen to
this this is what I want to do I want to
change our you know feature-wise and a
lot of the debt that we have is theirs
mine under student loans and you know we
both have credit card debt and two
vehicles and that type of thing so
mm-hmm so you make $160,000 a year and
you're broke and that's okay and that's
okay well I mean you know we live how 11
now as far as not a big savings and that
type of thing I mean numbers yes sir you
look good on the outside but when we
look behind the door there's nothing
there right yeah which makes you kind of
normal I mean most people they got two
nice cars the student loan that's been
around so long they think it's a pet and
a house you know yep and you know and
they're just all the money comes in all
their money goes out and they think well
this is it this is all there is we're
just a rat in a wheel right that's what
most people got the wheel I think so
it's a facade though and it's a lie
so okay I I don't know I can't tell
what's going on I hear did you go at her
hard-throwing the Dave Ramsey thing
around we got to do this all enthused
and so she's backing off because you
came at her so hard I didn't try to do a
hard sell I just was trying to say hey
you know this is a good I think it's
against a program for us I think we can
do it and you know I I'm enthusiastic
about it because I'll listen like I said
I listen me every day but I want to get
started on and I'm just trying to get
her on boards I know like you said I
don't want to do the ish so I don't want
to do it just me trying to do it on my
own well I think you need to dig in a
little bit and find out what's really
going on I can't put my finger on it
what you're saying you've got to find
out what her real objection is because
if her objection is truly that you can't
that you're stuck and that you can't
succeed making 160 thousand dollars a
year honestly that's just weird right I
mean that's strange if you made six ten
thousand dollars a year I could
understand how you felt stuck but 160
grand my gosh I mean you know you're in
the top 1% one and a half percent of
income earners in America and so you're
doing great income wise but you're just
horrible managers of it yep so maybe it
starts with a dream discussion like
Chris Hogan talks about and you just say
okay let's dream about where we could go
in the future if we got our crap
together
you know let's dream about what it would
be like to be worth several million
dollars let's look at that if we had
money what would you want to do would
you want a bigger house would you want
to travel would you want a better car
and then you know then you go okay well
you know let's look at what it takes to
get there because it's actually doable
with our income right and I hear it all
the time you know when you're talking
about our era the people come on you
know they're they're making
significantly less and they're paying
off your debts and I'm looking at it
like I want to be in that group yeah
absolutely absolutely and but the point
is you don't want to pay off debt just
about that you don't pay off debts so
that you get to do other stuff right
it's the so that that I'm talking about
and maybe you started talk a lot of
times with guys we go in and start
telling people what to
what we're gonna do instead of why and
you might want to talk to her more about
the why okay like the dream dreaming in
HD and how definition and so she says
I'd like to travel more than let's you
know get on some get on some websites
and start downloading some color
pictures of what that looks like okay
well you know where are we gonna go
we're gonna be sitting in one of those
funny little boats riding through Venice
you know I want to write that down I
want that on the wall right and that can
happen but we've got a you know we're
gonna have to be it doesn't it's not
gonna accidentally happen
there is no lone ranger that is coming
to save the day we are it and so once
you establish and you get excited about
dreaming again how long have y'all been
married we've been married for 13 years
dave yeah okay yeah once you get excited
about dreaming again like you're an 18
year old kid or something you know and
you go man I could do anything you
remember those days and you get to
thinking like that again then it makes
it worth it to make the moves and the
sacrifices to do something with your
life but hopefully you don't you can
have a created a created emotional
crisis that you create for yourself that
the two of you create for yourself where
you artificially look at this and go hey
everything's kind of going good but you
know what it still sucks and I'm not
living like this anymore and that's a
created crisis you're not in foreclosure
or repossession or collections you
haven't lost a job you're not about to
go bankrupt you don't have a real crisis
you've got a worse problem is is that
your mediocre and ok with it you can get
stuck in that more than you can get
stuck in a crisis because at least in a
crisis you know things suck right you
know and so you've got to create an
emotional crisis out of this but I think
the way to do that is to look into the
future and see in HD in high definition
you know I remember the first time I saw
an HD TV man it blew my mind cuz I grew
up in a you know with black-and-white TV
with a little rabbit ear things on top
with three channel
and man when I'm you know and then it
got better we got flat screens I got a
plasma right remember those and then I
got an LCD and then man we got a walk-in
and you can you know you can almost
smell smells from that HD I mean it's
unbelievable right and that's how you've
got to look at your dream it can't be
like this distant vague thing detail out
what it is I want a bigger house okay
what's the house got in it how many
bedrooms how many square feet how many
fireplaces
what's the kitchen got in it that our
kitchen doesn't have what color is it
what's the style of architecture detail
it out you may never build that house
but when you build it in your mind it
gives you something to sacrifice for
discipline is not a natural human event
it is the emotional maturity to delay
pleasure for a greater good that's what
discipline is it means you're a grown-up
I disobey away from the cookies because
I'm tired of looking at this gut okay
and so that it is him it is an emotional
thing I'm not gonna live thank God it's
Friday - oh god it's Monday the rest of
my life no discipline seems Pleasant at
the time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness the Bible says so nobody
likes it but we like what it takes us to
I saw a bumper sticker the other day I
thought was pretty good I said nothing
tastes as good as it feels to be thin
and I thought I'd like to experience
that someday but anyway right you know
this is my internal tapes right so
chocolate chip cookies are my downfall
but yeah the health is watering that's
awful anyway yeah see that's how
discipline works though you got to have
a greater good that you're reaching for
otherwise there's no it makes no sense
it's not logical to sacrifice in the
moment unless it's for something and the
for something the so that the why is
what matters here it's a great
discussion man thanks for calling in